(birds chirping)
(scraping)
- Thousands of years in
refining super efficient,
most efficient way of
doing this, I would say,
just like a bicycle's
the most efficient way
to put down miles.
Everything above and beyond this you get
is a diminishing return
in energy expenditure
and productivity output.
(scraping)
- It's like meditation in motion for me.
It's just really soothing,
and it puts you in connection
with the energy of the earth.
(scraping)
- It's nice and quiet.
I could do it when my kids were napping.
I could do it in the evening.
I could do it early in the morning,
and I didn't feel like
I was being a nuisance.
(loud scraping)
- I could go through with one pass
and then I go back through
two or three times, and
you just keep working it
closer to the edge, so you
end up with something that,
at times, depending on
the grass you're cutting,
you are, you tailor the blade
to what you're cutting.
(hammering)
So, if I was gonna be cutting
really thin, delicate clover,
you could make this thing,
you can run your fingernail
underneath it, and it
will create a ripple,
like a wave, 'cause you make it so thin,
but for the goldenrod and reed canary,
and that tougher kind of stuff like that,
that would be probably too delicate.
You'd end up then fracturing it.
- It feels so non-destructive
and gentle and
life-sustaining in a sense.
When we had the lawn mower,
you just run things over,
and with the hand-mower you
feel like you're a part of it,
and you can see the crickets
and the grasshoppers
jumping out of the grass,
the praying mantis,
you know, all of it,
it's like you're in their environment,
and you're not destroying them.
(scraping)
And when you're mowing, you
really are just focused on
the sound, the grass.
Everything else disappears.
(scraping)